okay so so the church we know we talked
about this basic structure I mentioned
this basic structure of the scripture
the garden and the the church fathers
especially sent out from the Syrian he
separates the garden into different
sections as well and so the Garden of
Eden has the Tree of Life which is at
the top of the mountain and then there
is the tree of the knowledge of good and
evil which is at a lower tier and then
there is the fig tree which is lower and
then finally at the bottom of the
mountain you have this wall with angel
protecting the garden and then you have
the thorns which are on the outside so
you can kind of imagine this basic
structure and then this structure is
then repeated in the temple itself so
you have the Holy of Holies where the
presence of God descends which is
equivalent to the Tree of Life and then
you have a holy place which would be one
step further back and then finally you
have the the outer court which would be
even further down the mountain if you
will further away from the garden and
then the outside is the land of thorns
outside of the temple itself are outside
of the tabernacle for example in Herod's
temple there was even a court for
foreigners so an very far out there was
a court where people who are not Jewish
were allowed to come but so you can say
it was always like more and more
restricted as you moved in towards the
Holy of Holies so the church has a very
similar pattern in this part we are in
the narthex and the narthex is a
transition part so it's a transition
between the inside and the outside and
so when for example in the traditional
Orthodox liturgy with nobody does it
anymore it seems but traditionally there
is a point in the liturgy the first part
of the liturgy it's forever it's for
everybody people can just could just
come the catechumen could come if you're
not if you were not Orthodox you could
be the
then at some point in the liturgy they
chase out the catechumens
after the sermon so they read the gospel
they they have the sermon and then they
say all the catechumens should leave and
other catechumen would walk out and
would come into the narthex and
traditionally they would receive
instruction they would they they
wouldn't go home like they would receive
instruction they would they would have
some kind of teaching for them but then
at some point they closed the doors of
the church they would actually close the
doors of the church and there would only
be the communicants who would stay
inside now you really have to understand
this this structure help us understand
how reality works it's to help us
participate in the way that that reality
works itself and so the narthex although
we don't do that anymore it still
liturgically plays that role so for
example if if a child is going to be
baptized they start out here they are
received at the door and there are some
prayers at the door of the church
prayers of exorcism you know and then
the person has to spit to the west to
spit at the devil and then there let
into the church so this is this whole
kind of drama of this entering into the
church from the outside moving in
towards the the inside of the church
another aspect that you see in for
example in greek monasteries you'll see
that a lot in in more modern times as
well as that they have the greek
philosophers in the narthex and so we
have icons of the saints inside but on
the in the narthex which is this
transition space it's still a space to
celebrate the intermediary forms even of
ancient culture and so knowing that the
Greek philosophers although they're not
Christian we can't just put them inside
right but they're also we use their
language we say we use the word logos we
use all these words that were developed
by these Greek philosophers and some
ideas as well and so we hold them in
this intermediary place and this is a
concept like if you've read Dante you'll
see the same thing dontoh does the same
thing with limbo he has this
intermediary space and then he puts all
the just pagans in this intermediary
space and it's mostly to understand this
thing remember I talked about this I
see also the foreign which is outside
and so the church has this space which
is this transition towards the inside
and what ultimately we can understand it
is also the place where the glory of God
can also it doesn't stop at the door of
the church right there it continues to
move out into the world from the narthex
out into the world as well it's not just
contained inside the church although
there is a hierarchy it's not contained
inside the church does that make sense
everybody all right and so if you turn
around you'll see the icons that are
represented here and so there are
different traditions of what you
represent in the narthex like I said
sometimes you represent warrior Saints
or sometimes you represent you know
transitional figures like the the
political figures or that kind of stuff
and here we have the Annunciation which
is here
which is also yeah sorry I'm my left
which is also the the name of the church
and so you come into the church and you
see right away the Annunciation you see
Gabriel announcing to the mother of God
and she is holding can i yeah so usually
yeah usually she's holding a spool of
thread in her hand
because she was mending the veil of the
temple she was she was made
participating in making the veil of the
temple so this is all part of our
symbolism of the mother of God as being
the holy of holy herself that she is the
holy of holies
she is the Ark of the Covenant she's all
this imagery of the place where the
theophany happens aware of where God
manifests himself and then on my right
we have the Nativity icon and so in the
nativity icon you also see you can see
it's similar it's almost as if they're
they are related to each other if you
look at the Annunciation icon you'll see
there's this ray of light coming down
from above there's a glory above and
there's a ray of light and in that ray
there's a little bird most of the time
and so you can see the holy spirit
coming down on the mother
God and here you see again this glory
and then you see this ray and the star
the Christmas star which is above the
cave where Christ is born and that cave
is also in a certain manner the womb of
the mother of god herself it's this holy
place it's this this this place of the
theophany all these images play on each
other in terms of understanding the idea
of a place where God manifests himself
and in the nativity icon what's
important to understand is you have
Christ you have the logos represented as
hidden in creation and so he's invisible
right no one knows and then you have
this you have these people who find out
and then they're drawn in towards this
invisible place and the drawing in is if
you look at the image it's like cosmic
the image of the Nativity is one of the
most cosmic images that that we have you
have the lower aspect of society the the
shepherds who are coming in you also
have these wise figures who are coming
the wise men were coming to see and the
wise men are also foreigners so you have
local people you have foreigners you
have the lowest class you have the
highest class and then you have above
you have all the angels which are
participating in this event as well so
it's really a cosmic event John adds
only father I'd like to add that there
is a tradition too or the narthex is
dimly lit whereas the church proper is
brightly lit because we come from the
darkness into the light and this this as
Jonathan mentioned this idea of liminal
entry into the church it comes from the
Latin word that means threshold and the
hod the community if that produced the
Dead Sea Scrolls in Qumran had a similar
type of entry into their into their
community and where the the initiates in
the community had to stay outside as
well for the for the practicing
Christian for the baptized Christian
though it's also a place of preparation
you know we don't just well some do but
we shouldn't you know come in and throw
yourself in the church sit down the pew
and you know like you're watching a
movie
there's a point of preparation so you
see the beeswax candles here's beeswax
is important because smells really nice
right it's all natural and there's
there's definitely an emphasis on
natural especially with lights although
we have electric lights here too about
oil and water lamps and things like that
talk about that later but the idea is
that you light a candle and there's
there's to a practice of lighting two
candles where you come and you light one
candle you'll come to the left side and
then you remember the names of the
living you'll come to the right side you
remember those of the dead and in this
way you're preparing yourself you're
praying for others outside yourself and
you're preparing yourself to enter into
the the kingdom into paradises work now
you'll see this as an engineer what
really appeals to me is this inner
harmony this this inner you know logic
to the services so you see the living on
the one side the dead on the other when
the priest prepares the gifts on the
Scott Ian on the patent the Lamb of God
is in the center and on the left of the
bread
yes risen the risen put peanut not lamb
lamb that comes up up at the home but
the lamb is that we use risen Brendan
the Eucharist on the left side particles
are placed for the living right and on
the right side particles for the dead if
you see the icon of the Transfiguration
crisis in the center on the left is the
Prophet Elias Elijah who never died he
went to heaven and a chariot of fire he
was of the living on the right as the
prophet Moses who died on Mount Nebo and
he died a natural death so he represents
the dead so you see this kind of inner
consistency and inner harmony in terms
of icons also it's very important is the
benefactor who's donating them and so if
they have a particular saint and a
devotion that seems to patrons say
they'll have that icon put there so that
will in terms of their are fixed icons
and then there's some flexibility to it
just a last note if just to give give an
idea what's happening here when you see
you'll see
the strip there oh I do see lines and
several letters are separate he's
blessing in his in his hands of solar
system method know if that any Kigali
bus a little going on repent for the
kingdom of the heavens is it all right
yeah we can go you can go go into the
church proper
so the the traditional the traditional
Church has a few basic patterns
there's the Basilica which is most the
one that in the West had become the most
prominent which has a longer longer
space and then an apse at the end but
the church the church structure that
really took up prominence in the East is
really this structure which is a dome on
a square cross and so here we really do
have like a basic very very simple
version of that sometimes it becomes
very complicated and when you're in the
church you you don't necessarily see it
right away you kind of have to to get it
sometimes there are more domes you can
add domes you can add all of this there
the different additions you can have
with the basic structure and this church
is like almost like a tight like it's a
cut it's a it's almost like a classical
type of that exact structure so you can
see the round dome and then you can see
that each on each side of the dome there
there's the extension of the cross so
the basic the basic structure is really
just heaven and earth that's the basic
ideas you have you have the dome of
heaven above then you have the earth
below you have to think in a flat earth
universe haha you have to not in a flat
earth the universe you have to think in
a phenomenological universe you have to
imagine that what you experience that's
has reality to it if you go outside and
you look up you see a dome tried not to
see a dome I don't know what you're
gonna see that's what you experience we
experience this dome and it ends up
having a symbolic important as well
because it's you have this perfect shape
of the circle and then below you have a
stable shape which is a square and you
have four corners but we still think
that we still say north east south west
if we look at a map it still organized
that way it still has the four
directions and so we have the same thing
and the four directions then also become
the extension of the cross itself which
extends out into the world so you have
the dome which is the invisible part and
the visible part is this extension you
can understand it as the in Paradise
there was the top of the mountain and
then there were four rivers that came
down the mountain and there they are
those four rivers it's the same thing
you have four directions you have four
rivers that extend from the summit and
and and fill up fill up the world now
this this is the first time that I see
this set up in the end of the church
most churches most churches now will
have an image of Christ up in the dome
and this church they put the image of
Christ up at the top of the arch when
most churches will have an image of
Christ up in in the dome and it's Christ
as pent okra towards Christ as the great
judge it's also Christ at the ascension
the first images of Christ up in the
dome were images of the ascension so you
see you would see the disciples around
then you see Christ up in the center
because the angel said that he will
return in the same manner that he left
and that's that's it that's the you have
the divine logos is right there above at
the very top the summit of everything
he's above everything in the world is
manifested through his speaking to his
his speaking creation he's judging the
world we always see judging as a as a
bad thing but judging is also just
deciding what is what right giving
identities and judging is the same thing
actually giving a name to something and
judging it is the same Act and so we
have this setup and here that you can
see the four the four angels in Hagia
Sophia this is how the pendant is are
done
sometimes there's also the four
evangelists are there sometimes it's
four angels but with the the different
eight the different heads of the of the
of the Tetra morph so you have
man the lion the bull and why am I
forgetting one the lion the Eagle it's
like and you can imagine it as the we
see we talked about this in the liturgy
we talked about how Christ is carried by
the hierarchy of angels down carry down
to us by this this hierarchy of angels
and this is the thing I was talking
about is that in the Christian world the
hierarchy is not we were so ruined by
the modern world because we always think
that high hierarchies are bad
Heike is always bad because they oppress
us or whatever and sometimes it's true
but in the Christian vision of the
cosmos the hierarchy is the way in which
we are able to all participate together
and so the Angels carry down the the
president of God to us and we sing with
the angels and we raise ourselves up
into that song with the Angels we're all
participating in the thing yes Father
you wanted to say something the word
hierarchy in greek means holy order
putting them to death I was persecuting
them they prayed for them because they
realized that without door was worse
than the world with a despotic and so
order hierarchy was even actually an
important crystal stone how he was the
imposition of the Falls required to keep
order right there the fit say that kind
of not a subjugation is a very inferior
life its participation it's a way that
we participate in in in the things above
us you know if you one of the
difficulties when you don't have
hierarchy and you see it all the time is
that you say just me and God right you
hear that a lot
Christians it's like I don't need all
this other stuff it's just me and God
the problem that happens usually is that
you they think it's me and God but it's
actually me and God because there's no
hierarchy to show them how lofty and how
infinite God is they make God into just
some guy like my buddy you know my
friend or whatever not the infinite
origin of all things it's just something
that is extremely accessible in that
sense so hierarchy helps us to
understand both the the distance that
separates us from God but also how we
are actually completely connected to God
at the same time and so is there
something else want to say about the
dome in the square contrast the dome due
to the steeple because the steeple
reaching up the gun right and you see a
distinction between the Moses theology
theological discourses Orthodox in the
Western world Orthodox etiology is
characterizes apophatic
we see that the prayer of the first
tentative on our liturgy we usually
words like a method I know it was
catastrophic dose unspeakable
unimaginable so God's levels beyond
compare beyond expression
you won't hear simile so the West will
try to figure out by asking questions of
God and they kind of in a scientific way
trying to figure out who God is which is
a possibility because if God is infinite
and going to your backyard
happen together and so as we said to
that the bumbaclot or Cattleman's to
hope right
so the public record is the one who hold
that's why he's the authority he holds
all in his hand the other crap talk
about Mexico star power in himself they
know Cathy Dennis there was a lot of
people nervous you see this a long time
in the churches
he's not holding the Bible is holding
the book away early Hospital do you
think tells us God in the book of life
and Jonathan's are the same you see this
year in cemeteries you see whether that
you know we think of worthlessness for
enriching but there's a flexibility
there's a necessity and an
expressiveness but it happens within a
framework so you won't get the Vinci
setting you know you admit you those as
well to pick you know John the Baptist
like this chubby kid here chubby Jesus
crawling around the feet of marriage you
won't get that there has to be the form
because they express the icons and I'm
sure John Tucker's who sport express the
transfigured person but the historical
first I was in a pizza shop
I'm using a piece of shocking Iran and I
looked at it like that bit this
assistant who's to us
he goes no significance great sensei not
a nicer side and this is how did you
know that exciting what my things look
like Nicholas expressing and historic
last comment on the dome this is used to
be there in the middle because there
were this this Western North whoops
it's the coffin cooker outrage in other
words on microphone so you're right
under the dome on in the big demo
acoustics so they can hear you of the
stone that sealed the tomb right so
the center it makes perfect sense
because the the pulpits there the humble
ones there in the center right under the
dome
there's the tools right there the stone
that seals into the thing on the dawn
it's very biblical this kind of
architecture because well the Bible
doesn't say the purpose of life is well
to save your soul go to heaven on cloud
nine and to play a harp the only thing
the Bible says is we're waiting for
Christ to come and so this is biblical
because it you said that the whole thing
ends in Revelation where it's the
marriage of heaven and earth it's that
heavenly City and it's also the imagery
of the marriage tells the city at the
very end and so that's what this is
depicting no words it's as if the sky is
falling on you so when a year Sofia was
first built the first people who walked
in it were afraid that you have deceived
it as if that dawn was gonna fall on
their head and it's supposed to because
it's supposed to portrayed this idea of
them the coming of Christ and that's
what the Bible is leading to it but we
in a very rational rationalistic and
very individualistic way we superimpose
Western ideas that the whole purpose of
life is to save my soul very
individualistic and we we we ignore the
community the communion the church the
body of Christ all those things have
been gone by the wayside Jeff
is the original design we were carried
over from lost yeah yeah the Hagia
Sophia is the basis of all Islamic
architecture the other thing father
would you said really help me to think
of there's something that I forgot to
explain is that all of Christian art
iconography architecture the the layout
of the church and the way the icons are
laid out is is all eschatological that
is it is all a participation in the
things to come it's all a kind of the
capacity we have to glimpse or to
participate in the final state when all
will be accomplished when all will be
revealed in the early churches it was
very dramatic the very early churches
had you know their twenty-four elders
and had all this stuff when I a lot of
people tell me you know Christians we
don't need this Old Testament stuff
right we don't why do we have altars and
and the Holy of Holies in and and all
that stuff but this is there is no lamb
on the on the altar in the Holy of
Holies in the Old Testament it's not
there
it comes from revelations it all comes
from revelations it's in Revelations
that everybody has turned towards the
altar and there's a lamb on the altar
and that we're all bowing towards the
altar it comes from the eschatological
moment where everything is revealed and
so the church decoration and the icons
and all this is all based on this this
capacity to participate in the eschaton
and you can imagine the the icons that
when you see the Saints represented in
this certain manner with the mark of
their holiness with a halo with gold and
all of this is the same it's it's the
peeking into the totality of their being
in the eschaton the capacity we have
already to be in that moment and to
participate in it
to this area so they are to the point in
the center that was the Soleil up there
over here we have the bishops throne the
bishops throne over here the Empress was
the millet system under Turkish rule
this match dr. Cofer for Jews for
Armenians but his people Christian
people and that's in that position over
there is the chance
because that's the image of the kingdom
he won't get on his stool and he would
also have all the press Pater's with him
and that's the nation gap in the first
century this is you know some people
like that is Jonathan's alluding to some
people are kind of all pain is on
Constantine's head and 312 who had
defeats extensions the million Brutus
miles outside of Rome to meet their
journey we do from Milan and then 325
the first council but this all predates
this is episodic Ignatius of Antioch who
was consecrated officials in 70 AD who
want to use that term anachronistic and
he was spent to the lines in one away
and he wrote to the church at
Philadelphia mat Pennsylvania right
where the bishop is there's the church
surrounded by such as befitting its
president urged his theocracy and
deacons presiding over the Eucharist
which is true the body blood of Christ
we have ecclesiology the church the
higher handles of the people in one
place correct the clement of rome talks
about this distinction that john i was
talking about there is a place with the
lady in that cross over for the place
where the priests for they're the ones
who preside with the sacrifice that's 19
[Music]
yes
yeah the other addition that that the
last liturgy in Constantinople when the
Turks came that all the the people the
presbyteries everything kind of like
disappeared into the walls and that
they'll come out to celebrate the
liturgy once again so so let's all go
back downstairs because we're gonna run
out of out of time everybody I hope you
enjoyed this visit of an Orthodox Church
the church was the Cathedral of the
Greek Archdiocese in Boston and the
priest with me his father Dmitri Tonia's
who is the Dean at the Cathedral there
if you enjoy these videos please go
ahead and share it really helps to get
the word out if you appreciate what I'm
doing it also support my efforts
financially you can go to my website the
symbolic Worldcom slash support there
you will find different ways to do that
supporters get an extra video a month
usually an interpretation of a story or
some phenomena there are also different
tiers of access ways to ask questions in
advance for my Q&A monthly and also ways
to have different types of meetings
monthly meetings yearly meetings with me
one on one to talk about your questions
or your own symbolic project and so
everybody thanks for your support and I
will see you very soon